bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le résumé
des ronds 5 et 6 des matches de
championnat du monde dansait 35 fabiano
caruana avec les blancs à jouer
d'ouverture une nouvelle variante rosso
l'iman contre la défense sicilienne pour
la troisième fois de suite et à nouveau
n'obtient absolument rien dans
l'ouverture et ce sont même les noirs
qui obtient un petit avantage magnus
carlsen avec les noirs ici après le
couvain détroit de la part des blancs a
joué le coup roi b6 peut-être une petite
erreur il aurait mieux fallu jouer le
coup bessac afin de fixer le client
faible le pion b4 et ensuite venir à
l'attaqué avec les pièces il a préféré
emmener son roi étant au final c'est
vrai que on peut penser que le roi doit
s'activer sauf qu'il reste encore
beaucoup de pièces sur l'échiquier et
fabiano caruana trouve un bon coup pour
jouer contre ce roi qui se retrouve un
petit peu exposés et trouvent le bon
coup fou des deux qui lui permettra de
replacer ces pièces avec le bouffon ou
trois échecs et par la suite cavaliers
b1 en c3 le caribéen qui n'a toujours
pas bougé les blancs en profite pour
replacer tout leur pièce au bon endroit
la suite fut au tour des huit pour
attaquer le pion des trois fous et trois
échecs
voilà roi b5 justifiant un petit peu
l'arrivée du rouen b 6 cavaliers ses
trois échecs petite pointe ici avec
l'idée évidemment si le roi noir
maintenant vient on à 6 ce sera
évidemment une grosse erreur
après tour un échec ce sera suivi du
matin puisque laurent noir n'a plus de
gaz les pièces noires sont obligés de se
donner les unes après les autres et ce
sera matt cain et ses trois échecs roi
prend b4 le coup forcé mais qui était
attendu cavaliers des cinq échecs fou
prend des cinq les blancs ont rendu un
pion et ils en rendent un deuxième
maintenant fou prend des 5 reprend des
cinq tours prend des cinq tours b un
échec pour activer leur pièce c'était le
problème de la position au départ malgré
leurs pions d'avancé les blancs avaient
une très belle exposition de pièces et
il arrive grâce à ses coups forcer un
activer leurs pièces quitte à rendre un
pion parce que dans la finale même avec
un pion de retard les tous les pions et
en luge de du même côté la position est
nul assez rapidement après 3 c3 tout
reprend bessette les blancs attaque le
pion au fc d'où le coup qu'à valider 8
pour le protéger et en même temps
attaqué la tour blanche les noirs vont
gagner le pion en d3 mais comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure ça ne suffira pas
pour ces sept échecs reprend des trois
rois et fin avec une petite idée
derrière la tête les blancs en veulent
encore essayé de jouer sur l'euro non un
peu exposé en créant peut-être un réseau
de maths
le réseau de maths on peut très bien
voir par exemple après le coup eux
quatre ici pour les noirs 1 qui
évidemment est une erreur en grosse
erreur grossière erreur
le cadre qui pourrait attaquer le kavé
en f3 sauf que lecavalier part avec
plaisir évidemment a eu un et c'est même
matin wall e le roi noir qui n'a plus du
tout de gaz
l'idée du courroye f1 c'est d'essayer de
faire ce coup cavaliers 20 mai en
anticipant le court 1 4 les blancs
voulait jouer probablement le coup j'ai
quatre afin de contrôler la dernière
case du roi au f5 par la suite d'où le
prochain coup les noirs qui aura
beaucoup même si ça ne suffit pas pour
gagner le coup à chaque empêchant du
même coup le coup j'ai quatre c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont loupé h3 pour faire ce
coup g4 est la leur au noir doit partir
pour éviter l' attaque des pièces
blanches 3 e 4 mais du même coup les
noirs sont obligées de rendre le public
allégé cinq échecs roi f5 cavaliers pro
f 7 quai précède
pour preuve cet échec five 6 et lala nul
était conclu maintenant les noirs n'ont
même pas de viande avance tous les pions
sont du même côté tours est fou de
chaque côté la finale est nul
avait plus rien à faire on passe
maintenant à la sixième partie dans
laquelle mecs nus ce qu'arsène avait des
blancs évidemment alors encore une fois
une ouverture très terne sans sans
vraiment de possibilités avec un échange
de dame très précoce une finale donc
très rapide où on avait l'impression
vraiment qu'il avait rien se passer
pourtant il va se passer des choses dans
cette partie on arrive ici au 43e coup
des noirs après le coup cavaillé d2 les
les deux joueurs en sont à égalité
matérielle de fouiller un cavalier de
chaque côté mais les noirs ont pris un
ascendant ils ont obtenu un pion passé
même si c'est un pion passé central qui
peut être stoppée relativement
facilement par le roi est encore
énormément de pièces sur l'échiquier
malgré tout un trois-pièces mineurs le
roi un petit peu de mal à venir devant
ce pion et les pièces noires sont plus
actives les pions de l'eelam sont un
petit peu fragile un le pion à deux peut
être une cible assez facilement alors le
coc cavaillé des deux des mois et dans
le but de prendre le fouet
3 bien sûr afin de conserver la sphère
de fou avec la paire de fouler - ouais
toujours un avantage avec leurs pions
passé en plus donc les blancs ici ont
voulu forcer une finale vraiment très
déséquilibrée très différent de
maintenant et très risqué aussi alors
qu'il aurait pu jouer peut-être de façon
un petit peu plus solide mais plus
passive aussi avec par exemple le coût
cavaliers en f1 après cavaliers pro f
3,3 points f3 des quatre échecs
effectivement la paire de fous des noirs
étaient quand même puissante le pion
passé était dangereux mais le roi blanc
reste quand même à côté du pion en tout
cas les noirs ont l'avantagé c'est vrai
que la défonce des blancs n'est pas
facile en tout cas au 44e coup ici
m'amuse car seuls à préférer forcé
la position en sacrifiant une pièce pour
3kg ans grâce au coût 44 foudre en d5
effectivement le pion est attaqué deux
fois par le caillou 3 et par le fouet 3
sauf que après fou prend des 5
il ya une suite de coups forcé qui
apparaît après fou prend 1,3 le fou qui
élimine le défenseur lecavalier ou trois
si les blancs près de ce fou en au 3éme
année noire maintenant pour on prend le
fond des 5 et faire échec
et c'est ça la différence évidemment le
fou blanc n'a pas le temps de prendre le
cahier leroy sera obligé de bouger et la
halle et les blancs auraient positions
perdantes qu'ils auraient qu'un seul
pion pour le cavalier s'écrit fier donc
après fou prend 1,3 les blancs ont joué
le seul coup fou prend ses six faux
procès si ce qui permet de prendre le
pouls de cases blanches
ici le pouls forcé des noirs est fou
prend un f4 les blancs ne peuvent pas
reprendre le fou sinon les noirs
reprendront du même coup le four blanc
en c6 est encore une fois auront un cave
évidemment ce contre un seul pion les
blancs profitent de leur fiancé 6 pour
prendre les pions beldame avec fu pro b
cet attaquant du même coup un troisième
pion des 6 et le fouest 4 toujours
attaquer au f4 qui s'en va food et 6 et
fo prompt à 6 finalement bilan des
courses qu'est-ce qui se passe
les noirs ont un cavalier de plus mais
les blancs ou trois pions pour ce
cavalier
donc on peut se dire que trois pions
c'est suffisant contre un cavalier dans
les finales ça ça devrait aller pour les
blancs sauf que c'est les deux pions des
lames sont fixés on voit le fou des
noirs en d6 qui bloque la poussée des
pions lecavalier qui est pas loin
donc il va pouvoir les attaquer assez
rapidement et les pions blancs des
droits qu'ils sont pas non plus très
très bien disposé et ils sont soumis à
des attaques envoie le flot des six
directement qui attaquent sur le pion g3
tout ça pour dire que les noirs vont
probablement réussir gagner un pion et
et après ils ont gagneront encore un on
va voir ce qui va se passer exactement
cavaliers quatre attaques le pion g3 au
passage j'ai quatre coups force et il
faut absolument conserver ce pion pour
conserver la majorité ici deux pions
blancs sur les droits la seule chance
normalement pour les blancs de faire nul
c'est d'arriver à échanger tous les
pions de l'est le roi 1 pour enlever
tous les pions des noirs ainsi les noirs
n'ont plus pions ils pourront plus gagné
sauf s'ils arrivent à gagner le fou
parce qu'on sait que la finale fouquet
alliés contre eux roi est gagnante mais
si les blancs concert leur faut
évidemment ce sera nul donc j'ai 4 x 3
un bon coup pour fixer le pion à 2 et
par la suite venir l'attaqué avec le
cavalier on veut lancer 3 évidemment en
c3 le cavalier attaquerait le pion à
deux pouces et quatre avec l'idée
probablement de clouer le pion à vii non
l'optique de jouer le coup j'ai cinq
menaçant évidemment après le coup j'ai
six donc les noirs anticipent cette
attaque avec le coup droit et fuite tout
simplement les blancs jouent g5 quand
même cavalier c3
voilà pour attaquer le pion à 2 et là
même où ce qu'arsène préfère donner plus
tôt le pion b3 plutôt que le pion à 2
parce que c'est vrai que ce puits on a
deux et plus éloignés par rapport au roi
mois en plus il fait dame fut une case
blanche donc les noirs et en ayant un
fou noir c'est peut-être effectivement
bien vu donc le coût bekkat certainement
un coût précis b4 fou prend des quatre
rois f3
alors là le flou un évidement c4 qui
protège évidemment le pion à deux
c'était l'idée du coup b4 bref trois le
roi vient soutenir ses pions sur les
droits continuons la partie cavaye à
quatre foulées 5k et c5 lequel et qui
tente de se replacer
l'idée du kawaii et probablement sevré
de se placer sur la case en 5 et 2
venir protéger ce cavalier grâce aux
coups f6 la lecavalier serait très bien
placé contrôlerait beaucoup de cases et
ans le 5
il empêcherait le roi blanc de venir
aider ses pions sur les droits dont
convenant angers 4 en contrôlant donc
cette case angers 4 à 4 m6 sera des
noirs prépare l'arrivée du cavalier
certainement eu 5
pour l'instant le cahier n'a pas de
passage en il peut elle est née en
dix-sept ni en d3 ce sont les deux cas
ce qui lui permettrait d' alors no 5
on voit la disposition un du fou en
bessin qui permet de contrôler ces deux
cases mais les noirs ont peuvent encore
gagner tant qu'ils ont encore des pions
sur l'échiquier
pour l'instant il reste deux pions
probablement rien n'aura plus qu'un
après les changeant f6 mais un pion
suffira si jamais il peut aller à dame
projet 4 voilà les blancs s'empresse
maintenant d'aller du côté droit avec le
roi pour viser probablement le trou
angers 6 qui s'est créé trois g4 pour
faire 3 5 celui de roi g6 afin
d'attaquer les pions cavaye quatre
cavaliers va chercher un chemin donc
pour aller sur cette fameuse case ont eu
il va y arriver normalement le chou
blanc ne pourra pas contrôler toutes les
cases du cavalier roi shaq fu 1 dans
l'idée de d'attaquer le pion hkd bien
sûr fou des trois attaques le cavalier
cavaillé des six voies l'avait cavaliers
apparemment va passer par la case f7
pour aller sur cinq
voilà son trajet le fout des blancs ne
peut pas l'empêcher
et ici le roi blanc et bloqué un leroy
l'on ne peut pas aller angers si simple
puisque suroît g6 les noirs prendrait le
client en h4 et défendrait le pion f6
puisque après pions m6 le fou pourrait
tout simplement reprend le pion et là il
reste un pion noire est probablement
maintenant
les blancs n'arriveront pas à tenir la
position parce que le roi noir sera
libéré de la défense du pion en g7 et le
cavalier pourra bouger aussi un et pour
par exemple soit venir attaquer le pion
en a 4 soit venir attaquer le pion au f5
avec le roi bien sûr donc là la position
des blanches ne doit être perdante
c'est pour cela que au 58e co magnus
carlsen décide de sacrifier son pion à
sac il sacrifier le pion passé très fort
pu me passer un coup un peu inattendu le
flou qui doit prendre le manceau pions
fo prend 1,5
maintenant j'ai pris un f6 japon f60 a
g6 voilà l'idée de à cinq délégations du
show pour que le roi puisse aller angers
6 afin d'attaquer le pion en f600 que
évidemment le pion h4 ne se fasse
prendre part le fou noir le fou noir qui
doit revenir défendre le purifient ci
dessous des 8 3 7 voilà les blancs
trouve un petit point pour le roi pour
une sorte de forteresse s'est créé pour
le roi blanc maintenant ça va être très
compliqué pour les noirs d'atteindre ce
roi la finale va durer encore un petit
moment mais ça va être le plan des noirs
va être très très difficile de trouver
pour essayer de de force et seront à
sortir de son trou
cavaillé f7 fous ces quatre cavaliers
5-fu des 5 x 5 h 5 ce pion qui doit
avancer sur case blanche pour éviter
d'être attaqué par le fou fou des deux
fois de maintenant les blancs attendre
alors lille et des blancs simplement en
mettant le choix de se mettre le plus
loin possible du cavalier et qu'il se
fasse attaquer et de rester
principalement sur cette grande
diagonale de façon à empêcher l'eau
renoir de bouger ici si le roi noir
bouge par exemple si les noirs font roi
en recettes
le roi blanc maintenant pourrait aller
au g7 et laisserait libre
le passage aux pions h donc le pion
menacerait da da dam et là du coup les
noirs ne pourront probablement plus
gagné du tout donc laurent noir ne bouge
pas il a bien raison il n'a joué qu'un
voyage trois fous des cinq cavaliers des
4 et la 3g 6 peut-être qu'il fallait et
c'était possible de donner ce pion f5 en
jouant en jouant le coucou c4 mais
c'était quelque chose qui était très
difficile à voir dans la partie et donc
il a préféré défendre le pion angers 6
qui va laisser une possibilité pour les
noirs mais c'était difficile à trouver
après fou g5 des champions évidemment
alors si les blancs ici jouent le coup à
chis pour essayer d'aller à dame il ya
la pointe cavaliers eux deux et sur
achète ya un très joli mat avec
cavaliers f4 match voilà ça c'était
l'idée des mois un petit maths en finale
avec fouet cavaliers donc ce pion peut
pas l'avancer après fou g5y là elle a
bien vu sa d'entre les blancs ont joué
le coup pousser 4 et l'a probablement
les lois ont raté une manoeuvre de gains
qui était très compliquée qui était il
fallait jouer ici le coucou h4 pour
quelle raison on joue faux h4 en fait
c'est plutôt un coude attentes
c'est un coup d'attentes on met les
blancs en zigzag ici alors plusieurs
coups possibles avec les avec les blancs
alors pourquoi on soupçonne parce que le
fou en c4 a besoin de rester sur la
diagonale à 2 g 8
pour éviter que le roi noir viennent en
g8 si l'on revient au g8 lors on en
vient au g8 après il pourra bloquer la
case de promotion du pion le pion sera
plus dangereux le cavalier et le fou
pourront venir
chassez le roi blanc de son trou
finalement le faire reculer
et au bout d'un moment les noirs
gagneront les pions donc le foot doit
rester sur cette diagonale mais il doit
rester aussi sur l'autre diagonale pour
empêcher le cavalier de venir en eau
dont on a vu tout à l'heure la menace de
maths de ce cavalier donc par exemple
sur le coup food et 5 pour quand même
conservé le fou sur les diagonales les
noirs joue à cavalier e 2 avec
évidemment la menace de venir en f4 en
faisant échec et on attaque en dessous
mais surtout en attaquant le pion au
grand âge 5 lors les blancs auraient pu
le défendre donc il faut le défendre
tout de suite avec fouet f3 et la
lapointe c'est sûrement le coup qu'il
avait pas prévu c'était le coup cavaillé
g1
alors l'idée de ce coup c'est simplement
d'attaquer le fou pour pouvoir en
faisant à coup fort c'est donc le fou
sera obligé de bouger pour pouvoir venir
en g8 avec le roi s'il vous vient
ailleurs que sur la ligne l a2 g8
ignorant le courroye g8 donc par exemple
furent et six sur food et 5 donc sur flu
g41 évidemment roi g8 et sur food et 5
il est noir serait de jouer ou g5 et par
la suite de revenir avec le cavalier
soit en eux 200 en h3 pour aller sur la
case en f4 et finalement gagné le pion
s'il est blanc tentent d'avancer leurs
pions lâche ici a toujours la fameuse le
fameux schéma de maths avec camaïeu 2 h
7 et cavaliers f 4 mètres qui réapparaît
voilà la pointe que les noirs pouvaient
avoir dans cette partie dernière
variante après le coup fouache 4 la
possibilité pour les noirs de jouer à
chis directement puisque le cahier n'a
pas accès à la case f4 mais c'est pas
grave il va aller sur les cases f3
cavailles f3 h7 cavaillé eu cinq échecs
hélas la pointe c'est que non seulement
le cavalier fait échec donc la chasse et
l'on va chasser le roi mais en même
temps le
on sait 4 est en prise donc là ce qui
change absolument tout maintenant après
le courage 5
donc là les blancs attaque le fou et
menace de faire là mais ça n'est pas
grave puisque le fou en c4 étant aux
prises les noirs vont simplement
protéger la case promotion genre g7
et si les blancs prennent le fou et
benoît reprendront le fou aussi
ensuite ils prendront tous les pions et
gagneront la finale il a raté ce coup
qui était quand même très difficile 68e
coût des joueurs étaient fatigués ça
faisait déjà six heures qui jouait ou
presque
voyant la fin de la partie cavaillé f3 a
été joe 68e coup maintenant le roi blanc
s'empresse alors de revenir on achète
bien jouer voilà là maintenant
normalement le roi et reste en
forteresse il ya plus moyen de gagner
peut-être qu'il aurait dû revenir en des
cats avec le cavalier signé venir aux 5
fu b 3 kb/j qu'à toi là ça c'était le
plan attendu le fouet le cavalier qui
viennent bloquer la cada chis pour
éviter que le pion avant de saddam
ensuite le roi noir va pouvoir sortir
simplement ça servir à rien il n'y a
aucun moyen de progresser après poussé
quatre cavaliers trois fous des 3 kg 4
pouces et peut-être qu'avec schiste
voilà le cavalier qui vient fixer le
pion roger six recettes four b3 droit
des six pouces et 2 3 1 avec food et
trois pouces et deux cavaliers g4 four
b3
il n'y a aucun moyen pour les morts de
progresser il a tenté cavaillé e3 pour
aller prendre le pion en f 5 mai à chis
le pion va à dame
il est obligé de sacrifier son fou sur
le pion et et à proposer nul parce que
évidemment les blancs peuvent au lieu de
prendre le faut prendre plutôt le pion
en f6 est évidemment la finale flou
cavaliers contrefous émue elle donc
nouvelle nul dans cette partie mais
fabiano caruana est vraiment passé pas
loin du tout de la victoire merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette analyse t
il ce petit résumé et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour le résumé des prochaines
parties